meantime dozens of animal rights
activists march for change today
demanding the animal foundation do
better for the animals inside victoria
saha spoke with those rallying and with
staff at the animal foundation
no kill las vegas organized this protest
so they can be the voices for those
animals inside they say enough is enough
and every animal in there deserves to
live protesters gathered at freedom park
and marched their way to the animal
foundation many with signs that say they
want the shelter to stop killing the
animals inside others complained
management issues led to staff quitting
which ultimately leads to the lack of
care for the animals rose gotalero deals
with rescue animals she says she hears
of a lot of them being euthanized there
are an enormous amount of animals that
are being euthanized for not a very good
reason
pertaining to anything from an ear
infection to space issues the animal
foundation acknowledges they have had
staff issues but say they have been
doing better for the past 10 years we
brought our euthanasia rate down by 93
percent so we've dealt with them a
little bit but
we're doing great work ultimately these
protesters want to see someone running
the place that has experience working
with animals and will do their best to
make sure every animal gets a chance to
survive and get adopted reporting from
the animal foundation victoria saha live
local now